hello everybody hope you are having a
good
mid week i was gonna say start of your
week and then i realized that it's not
true
we are middle of the week which is kind
of scary when i think about it because
the weeks are gonna fly by
but anyways so today we are going to
continue looking at magnus's games today
this month is the magnus month i don't
know why but
we kind of considered that idea and ah
thank you
for the explanations on the title
and the chat too so yeah that's kind of
the the thing we got going so
i i'm looking live it seems to
everything seems to be great oh
hi yeah so we are gonna continue
uh this is a kind of a cool game it's a
game between
magnus and evan truck and i thought it's
a very interesting game especially
because
uh magnus really just uh played very
beautifully and it was not
such a long game because i've realized
when we do longer games if it's like
more than 40
40 something move then we're gonna have
a lot of trouble
actually finishing up in time and then
we're gonna have to
run through it and it's not gonna be
very pretty so i've decided to
try to select games that are only
um 30 to 40 moves if it's even shorter
even better
but uh between two super strong players
we usually don't get below 30 moves
although there was
very fun game between magnus and
nakamura that i showed a few weeks ago
that definitely was one of the shortest
ones
so let's get going
[Music]
and uh
i don't need to do a youtube trial all
right so this was a very cool game
and the opening is kind of well boring
honestly i'm not
let me rephrase not necessarily boring
but very basic it's like
we've seen games from magnus that he
starts with like first move c3 or like
he does scandinavian or like stuff like
that we are
not necessarily this is not a game like
that and by the way this is a game in
2011
billboard i believe and
i thought it was kind of fun because uh
2011
i was not really uh
hearing that much about chess i mean i
was playing tournaments and i even went
to brazil in 2011
for worlds uh youth championship and i
got
uh fifth place and it was kind of cool
but i wasn't like looking at it like oh
i'm gonna
um i'm gonna like be like a super title
player
or i'm gonna actually be professional so
kind of weird to think that's 12 years
ago
yeah so um
oh thank you everybody for being awake
and being with us
oops sorry that was my back all right so
let's get going
uh i do play the songs black and that's
another reason why i thought it's kind
of a cool game to show
it's the uh
so many lines that i've done a little
from white side from black side we've
done different videos
and not just me a lot of other streamers
a lot of the club teachers have done
videos with on f3 on e3
on uh the classics with like a3 they're
just like you name it we've done it so
um
it's very important to keep an open mind
about what's going on
here yeah kind of not necessarily uh
fleet gambit declined but like if black
does end up playing d5 sometimes black
doesn't black goes for like these setups
or
tries to keep the keep this diagonal
open and doesn't play d5 so it's very
important to just
keep an open mind oh i hear subscription
lovely thank you for youtube
subscriptions all right so
let's get going uh in this game magnus
played knight f3 knight hamstring is one
of the
relatively less i don't want to call it
calm ones but
less crazy ones yeah definitely
relatively one of the less crazier ones
supposedly but then we're gonna see
because in a lot of the lines especially
if the
if black is not as experienced again
black is a bunch so that's not
what we're going for here black could
get tricked into a
white plank e4 not right now but like
with queen c2 e4
or like uh trying to go e3 get the
knight out of e2
and then push for e4 a lot of like e4s
in there
so that's another thing to keep in mind
however
in this situation that's not necessarily
the worry
of this game and
so knight f3 uh yeah
it's very it became very popular in um
during that park with a sparrow match in
18 1985 i believe yeah
and it's very important because that's
something that
like again this is 13 years ago well
actually 12 years ago
hold on what's wrong with my math that's
10 years ago what why do i think it's
2013 2023
oh boy i'm getting my years wrong
usually you get the days of the week or
the months wrong but in this case i'm
adding two years to everybody's
yeah this is this game is 10 years ago
and i don't want to confuse anybody but
in the 1985 match between carpool and
kasparov
this became quite popular so if you're
if you have not really spent enough time
uh learning about that match go dudes
well not right now first make sure to
stay here during our stream and deco
watch videos and go read the books about
that match because
it's really important to um
to understand what's going on in the
chess history not necessarily like
every single detail but just the big
stuff you gotta you gotta know the big
stuff and just history
anything if you like uh oh this was
funny i was looking at memes from
medicine
and um there was this very funny meme
about like
um anastasia became a thing in like 1947
and like the doctor before that so
doctors like will just punch the
patients that is not true
to my knowledge but that was just fun so
like
it's like you know little little little
stuff to pick up from here anywho
and in this game evancheck wins for b6
i'm a big fan of b6 but that doesn't
necessarily mean that b6 is the only
thing to do you can definitely do stuff
like d5 as well
and if bishop g5 then this is another
tank that was played i believe aronian
played it
um like two three years yeah in 2014 so
three years after this game was played
with mamadirov and he won it but again
these are just suggestions of what's
going on and now and you get spun
carlsbad pawn structure and the fight
for this
um this cool diagonal
so that's another thing to keep in mind
with the d5
and let's see what else can we do what
about c5
c5 um definitely doable
i i like c5s generally when i play names
indiana's black
i feel like c5 is gonna keep my uh keep
my options open do i wanna play d5 i'm
not gonna play d5
i've just had a better feeling on this
and this was one of the games
between kasparov versus karpov in moscow
in 1985
they're the world championship match
which caspar went with g3
and this kind of uh this knife d4s when
you play c5 are very common
can be followed with f5 sooner or later
the d5 is possibility too but like
this whole playing against double pawns
i kind of like it but doesn't
necessarily
work every time so yeah and
in this game white uh
i believe one
please correct me if i'm wrong on this
but i believe this key this is
the 13th game that's why it did win
anywho let's go back so i'm just showing
you possible lines
from the opening usually well that's
what we do i kind of introduce
different ideas to you and then i show
you what the players did
so i want to play b6 now what about
castle
one last line castle again
white can just play queen c2 or bishop
d2
but in uh one of the games that
is popular is uh game
and he went for bishop g5 and just
finished developing queen side first and
then slowly slowly went back to deal
with the king side
but by the time he went that
black kind of had already made some
serious
uh changes to the position so it wasn't
i mean white had more uh opportunities
to
figure out how to continue and it's not
necessarily like okay i gotta put my
bishop here
like just short castle it was it gave
the game a little more oomph
i guess i've learned the word
more recently so i'm hoping that i'm
using it in a correct
content so feel free to help me with my
english too
anywho uh this game i do prefer white so
that's not the point i think
it's more pleasant to be a pawn up even
though if it's
double pawns and have a stronger king
these two kings compare are not really i
mean this going on g8
is not exactly the dreamboats when g5
happens also white has two bishops
anyways just introducing potential ideas
so in the real game in evantrix game we
want you went for b6
magnus continued with queen c2 again
their
ideas with e3 you did not have to right
now g3
bishop g5 there are so so so many
different
ways to play names on the indian that i
if i just talk about different lines
we're going to run out of time
and patience so now let's just continue
in this game magnus decided that he
just uh whenever check i mean if we
could i would like to pick up three
bishops but i don't think that's
possible
i mean if the e5 happens then we can
consider queen a4
more seriously oh are you talking about
right now what if d5
but if d5 point a4 just like c6
stops it and i don't really have d5
myself if i could play d5 and like you
know uh
pin the knight i would but it's good
good eye
you're making connections but i don't
think that works here
all right so uh now magnus was
really wanted to just figure out what's
going on here
not a bad idea when i work with my
younger students i always encourage them
to poke the poke
the the thing that's pinning them
and they seem to like it so kind of
makes it more easy to handle like okay
so i don't want to be pinned so let's go
and um just
figure out what this bishop wants to do
and usually when the bishop does come to
b4
it's very unlikely for it to uh that's
not going to happen it's certainly
unlikely for it to
stay around it's definitely more likely
to just
you know do this exchange and finally
knight e4 okay who is under attack we
got to come back
and f5 so this this position from black
side is something that i actually play
as black
so let's see how magnus would beat me if
we played like this
um so in this position i'm gonna
oh another another subscriber lovely i'm
gonna
ask a few questions and i would love a
good interaction from audience so
what do you guys think white should be
doing the first thing to figure out is
which side you want to cast on
probably we're going to do short ted
castle right alongside castle is
doesn't really feel safe after all these
pawn movements and there's not much
pieces protecting it so we're
most likely gonna do short side casting
unless black makes like a huge blunder
and
the game just ends before we cast them
and so in order to do that we're going
to figure out what to do with this
bishop
now which so we have two
potential routes for the bishop which
one do you suggest which one do you
think is a better one
honestly i think both of them are doable
so it's not uh maybe it's not about
which one is better it's more like
preference which one would you prefer
horsey to e5 um my teeth doesn't really
serve a purpose
we really gotta figure out how to get
the king to safety
interesting i'm seeing more g3 than e3s
yeah and the game magnus went for g3 but
e3 is
just as possible and if e3 let's say
castle you get the bishop out and you
just castle and
whose game was this i was looking at
this earlier
uh oh
a lot of subscribers yeah this was
actually a game that was played between
carl
the kramnik and polgar judith
and uh so in this game for example they
decided comics decided to just
go for the queen side while gg twins
were the king side so it was kind of a
fun game to
watch and i always like it
when there's different side the text
it just i don't know how to explain it
it's more like uh
more challenging not maybe not
challenging it's not the right word
more um alive i feel more alive and
there's like
you attack here i'm gonna attack there
yeah and it just kind of feels more
interesting too
but then again uh nothing it doesn't
necessarily have to be like that
i just have a preference for this
anyways uh
white already does have advantage in
this type of position
because uh the the attack on the king
side is not really that strong
it doesn't really have much purpose and
in this game
i believe kramnik oh actually ended up
winning even though judith is doing
whatever she can
to hold an attack the attack is not
strong at all and the pieces are very
disorganized there's not enough
material oh a low jack check to try
and um get this position to success
and yeah this was a game between chronic
poger
which kramnik won in 2005.
anyways let's go back a lot back
so yeah did you guys enjoy watching
kramnik play
in the latest lack of grand chess
because i thought it was fun because i
think he announced retirement from
classic
chess standard chess i guess um
last year or so and it was kind of fun
to see him back
just for the fun of it and not classy so
technically he's still retired
but i like to watch it anyways in this
game
magnus went for g3 logical right with g3
the idea is quite clear i am going to
fiance to this guy and i'm going to
short castle
good luck so knight goes away bishop
h3 how do you feel about this bishop h3
shocked happy what do you think
what do you think this bishop h3 has
all right i'm going to give you guys
maybe about a minute and now i'm going
to
give you some comments on what's going
on here
this was a new idea at the time so 10
years ago this was a new idea
so what do you guys think is happening
here
what do you think white wants the
special on f5 there's a pawn on e6 so
how does that
how does that work
all right i think you guys are just as
confused as i was when i first saw this
and yeah so the idea is that yes even
though
uh this is blocked right now
this does bring more future pressure
exactly thank you
with d5 idea so it's more like a
future idea like bishop bishop h3 makes
sense
only because what's going to happen
later and
yeah i agree yep
this d5 coming up could be quite
interesting
so and then there's another question
what about this g6 i don't think we need
to dress it much because we have a dark
skirt colored bishop and if you
push this g6 it's just like a already
funeral home for your
king slide squares so i don't think we
should worry about this g6 at
all it weakens everything in the coins
the king side way too much and is
to be worth it a lot of subscriptions
thank you thank you everybody yeah so
um now black just cast note magnus just
castled and evan tripp was just you know
what
i'm just going to push for a5 now a5 is
this a good idea or not
to be fair it is a stopping b4s at least
momentarily
so do we like this idea or do we think
there was a better idea
so he just played a5 my question
just to repeat it did black make uh
inaccuracy
was there anything better to do except
for a5
and while you guys think about it i'm
gonna throw in some ideas
in there remember in uh this
type of pawn structure especially like
all of black's ideas are in the king
side
so it does make sense to want to
blockade the queen side before we shift
everything to kingside
but at the same time and a lot of the
time it's very risky to
initiate the first move in um
in like the side that you're not playing
and so initiating this first uh like
attack or blockade i guess could be
it could be quite um heavy it could have
a very heavy cost it could be very
expensive
uh overall so was this a good move or
would it be better to just you know
shift these pieces around here
and also what's stopping white from
playing d5
so just looking at this position for a
little bit so we get
this like bunch of like ideas that okay
white probably wants d5 what probably
wants to do like b4 bishop v2
so white's going to be playing in center
slash queen side black is going to be
playing in center
kingside so
yeah it might have been a better idea
for black to have played this
queen e8 now if d5 queen h5
and this bishop is under attack so you
gotta move this bishop so it's
it's relieves pressure from f5 and then
this could happen
and i believe this was a game that
happened a year
or two a year after uh the current game
so the the position that i'm showing you
is a game that happened
um between two other grand masters a
year
after yeah in 2012 and so why play drug
d1 on white
sorry still does have a more preferable
position
but black is doing fine too
good point stonewall could be quite
risky if
you are not an amateur however if for
my students my beginner students i want
them to
get to attacking so i do teach them
that's like
stonewall attacking ideas maybe with
like the bishop on f4 first maybe like
london mixed with stonewall but that i
feel like
that idea to just get the kids attacking
is good
because i have some students who are
like very
mature when it comes to attacking and
then they know
nothing about empty and like this this
kid was really good like i've been
working with him for a while now and
we had like a position um like literally
end game with an extra rook no bomb just
an extra and he couldn't win it and it's
really started to
shake me that oh yeah super basic candy
canes might not be very basic
all right so the e5 cool idea now what
if a5 what stop
why can't i just play d5 should i play
d5
and this a5 is also kind of preparing
for knight a6
to you know for this knight to have some
activity
on the queen side of it so
d5 is definitely a good
candid move for white what else do you
think
is worth it
now let's take a quick look at d5 i
think d5 would be quite interesting
and the position kind of starts to open
up for the bishops and white has two of
it black only has one so that seems to
be beneficial
if something like we need now we could
even do like a knight d4
to keep bringing pressure on these bad
boys
i think that would be quite interesting
or even like bishop force just develop
it and get the bishop involved too a lot
of different
little stuff that could lead to
mini improvements all right so
i think this is again still a fair game
but i would definitely prefer to be
white than black
so
a5 in the game however magnus continued
with rook d1
i don't know how to feel about it i
don't know if this was like a uh
inaccuracy or he just felt like d5 was
too early
i don't know what he felt but he
definitely does have the d5
idea because he played bishop h3 which
is supporting d5 indirectly and then he
like played rook t1 which is supporting
d5 directly so he wants to play d5
that's not the question
finally black played queen e8s now is 28
good
because there is another idea with
bishop e4
this kind of reminds me of some of the
catalan moves that i used to play
yeah like get the bishop out and then if
the clean moves
what would these be dicks oh sorry i'll
speak out
yeah i kind of like this actually from
black i think it's a little bit
more um annoying than just queen e8
and if you play queen yes now okay okay
let's make some
attacks and again i think white
is overall a little bit better but
at the same time black does have a
little bit more activity
than the the just to clean e8 this
bishop on e4
kind of messes with white's harmony just
a little bit
yeah now also
probably c5 coming up soon so keep that
in mind
all right eventually just went for 28
now
is it time to finally play this d5 we've
been talking about this d5 for a few
moves now is it time
or do we still have to wait for it
what do you guys think pork girls
any cool ideas
oh getting the bishop involved could be
but
so if you want to do anything except d5
what's scaring you from d5 because we've
been preparing for this is it finally
time
oh another
what do you think
so each one wait e2 pawn is not really
hanging what is
um i don't think that's something to be
worried about i think d5
is the right time now yeah we gotta go
for this d5 now um
sorry a lot of i don't know what
happened
maybe i got emotional over d5 uh finally
d5 is happening
my little d5 is going off to college oh
all right now uh d5 is i think it's a
good idea
finally we've been waiting for this only
for like the past i don't know like six
moves
so good to finally have it out of the
way
however i think it might be an
interesting idea to think from
from black's perspective so what's he
gonna do in previous lines we saw
suggestions with queen a5 and queenish
file and then we
considered this potential night jumping
over here because
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna do a little flex
um
from uh
from i think the very first
youtube video that i did for the chess
club i did a game of mine that was like
a january 2020. yeah i did a game of
mine
that i won as from blackside
in a game that was very similar to uh
this idea is like
my uh i might be able to put the link
here too
and it was very fun because i did the
similar things as black is doing i tried
to like fix it over stuff over here and
get my knight two fun squares oh it was
a different
route but still i got the knight to get
to b3 and i had the pawn on a4 and i had
everything fixed on
queen side and then i started doing step
in the kingside and i ended up winning
that game
but anyways this kind of gave me a
little deja vu
all right so there are some holes here
that white has to be cautious when you
play
when you move any pawns you gotta be
very careful about the holes that you
leave behind
that sounded like a very uh quotable
thing
anyways careful with your pawn movements
so knight day six
i like it after knight to six
um we know what black wants to do so
there what do you got what do you guys
think what should juice because now we
have this whole ginormous hole here that
white
definitely wants to jump into so what
should we do
and uh naim eventually yes not tonight
however if you have games that you have
played previously
uh in about half an hour so we are gonna
switch to twitch
and uh you can you have the chance to
send me your games
in our twitch channel so we can analyze
them
yeah this fun segment of switch to
twitch
previously caleb used to do that but
he had to listen up his load i guess
so he gave me his switch to twitch
lesson
e6 idea before yeah i like his idea like
to do e6 or like b4
i mean sorry not e6 uh d6 to like b4
it could be interesting but right now
before you just drop the pawn so i'm not
necessarily that
because the big problem whenever you
want to play b4 is this stroke is lonely
so now we're getting somewhere if the
stroke is going to be lonely
what should i do probably shouldn't move
this bishop so that my rook is supported
right
so where do you think that bishop should
go
where do you got going
okay okay okay so i like it you guys are
finally
agreeing and getting the bishop out so
now the question is where
uh oh that's a good question is it
better to exchange this bishop with this
knight
no i don't think so because uh this
bishop
is my like secret weapon that's the one
bishop that opponent doesn't have right
and i agree yes bishop before this
bishop that opponent
doesn't have he only has the light
squared
bishop right so i want to be able to use
this bishop
that's like my secret weapon or like my
tiny advantage or however you want to
see it
that's the one thing that black does not
have
any who in this game rights now black
made an
accurate movement he just took from evan
chuck it's not exactly
um expected you know super high level
chess player has been around for like
decades he's been playing high-level
chess probably before i was born
okay maybe that might be an exaggeration
but um
before my chess carrier was born let's
go with that so
i don't necessarily like this take so
what about queen h5 queen h5 is indeed
the better
choice because now this bishop is kind
of hanging around here we got to save it
now the the pressure on f5 is relieved
and now
black can take it now keep in mind if
you take it there are two attackers here
so that's not gonna pan out we gotta
we gotta play more sneaky so if you play
something like knight d4
we're pinning over here and we're
bringing more pressure on this
it seems to be going well right and then
recreate now there's another pressure
over here
there's so many little pressure points
and let's say we end up in this type of
position
and black actually does get
quite a nice compensation for potential
sacrifice
and that's just something to be very
cautious about
sorry not necessarily this stuck because
that'll actually be interesting too but
even if we take it
black does get a good um good head start
on the piece activation and i'm going
yet upon his king so i think that's
quite interesting even if like bishop f3
queen moves
take take and something like bishop e3
to keep everything
good and tidy it's still not gonna be
that pretty
uh i would actually prefer to be black
here yeah
so this is not the only i mean if you
play q5 it doesn't give you advantage
that's one thing that we've been talking
a lot a lot about
in different classes that i teach just
that
we don't like the idea that white
uh sorry not white that the opponents
can just do whatever they want
we're not just fighting for the
advantage we're fighting to make
opponent uncomfortable too
and this queen h5 does make white quite
uncomfortable and also it does
make it a little bit easier for black to
activate the pieces
so bishop g2 uh there's a question about
what about king g2
um definitely possible to consider but
your bishop is quite trapped here if if
black would just get this pawn to g4
that's it that pawn that bishop is a
gonzo you can't really hold it hold on
to it then you can't really come back
and um yeah exactly something like even
h6 and then g5
g4 could work or even if not
um even if you just do this queen h5 and
you just hold on
after king g2 you can't really do much
here right now as white your bishop is
stuck here
forever so i don't really think that's a
good idea
uh so bishop f4
ed5 and
finally what eating magnus did
this is a take this is a take oh tim i'm
glad you brought it up
i've been waiting to be a little sassy i
haven't been able to be sassy
in a while because i'm a woman
grandmaster video trainer and an
international master and i work for the
club and you came to my channel
so welcome thank you tim
ah i miss being sassy right
so what do you think white should do
oh don't worry tim just gave me a chance
to flex off a little
i've been waiting to do that for a while
so what do you think what do you think
what should do here
oh i like
i like it when i hear the subscription
noise
maybe i should just have it as my
background noise
all right what do you think white's
gonna do
yeah so taking on f5 is definitely
a fun thing to do taking on d5 is
something that we should consider but i
don't think that's the right way
because if we take it we're just
activating the opponent's pieces right
if we take it
then the knight will take now my bishop
is under attack and then i don't want to
activate my opponent's pieces
uh so how about just bishop f5 yep
and so also keep in mind that this game
was played
two years before magnus was the world
champion
so i just wanted to point that out so he
was still
i was gonna say baby but he wasn't a
baby because he already had
uh wait has he already crossed the
rating barrier oh no no
he hasn't broken the kasparov record yet
rating wise but he was
very close this is i believe few months
before he succeeded
yeah this was in actually i don't know
the months but bilbao tournament is
usually
have always been in summer that i
remember
and he broke kasparov's record
in the london so december end of the
year to
2011. so a few months before he uh
officially became the highest rated
player in the history
this is that game well not that game one
of the games that led there
anywho yeah bishop f5 is a good idea and
if d takes c4 what do you think
yeah there are a lot of these super gm's
who became grandmasters at such a young
age
and when i think about it when i was
like 13 14
i still didn't know if i wanted to play
just
full time and actually like
i was always trying to balance it with
chess and school but a lot of the
a lot of these um super talented people
just has already made that decision said
no to school
and said no to like college and
everything and just went for chess
but i could i'm still balancing it so
yeah i think i did take a gap year after
high school to improve my chest
which i got my titles in that year but
still
all right so bishop f5 and yeah so
um it's taking over here it's
not a good idea because you're not
activating any of your pieces
yeah you're opening up your bishop but
um
this bishop is is active enough
uh it's not exactly
that hard for this bishop to be included
in the game
rather than the knights so we gotta we
gotta start thinking about the knights
so um this take is quite inaccurate
knight to e4 would be the best move
let's see i think knight c5 is also
worth
considering but knight c5 kind of uh
gives white the chance to go for b4 and
we don't exactly want to
you know be nice to our opponents we
want to kick and bite
so this definitely does not kick and
bite
that's not a biting move knight e4 would
be an interesting choice because now
this bishop is lonely if you take it oh
now black is actually better in this
position a lot of sacrificial chances
it's like gotta move
the piece activity you name it black has
it
all right so uh bishop h3
and then
yeah bishop h3 and queenish five this
would be
black's best chance to activate his
pieces
to you know fixate on the king side
queenside for a while
start attacking a kingside it doesn't
necessarily mean that black is going to
have advantage
no white still has advantage but it does
mean that
black would have a better chance at
achieving
anything except for a loss in this game
and yeah so uh
dc4 and now what do you think white
should do
are we gonna take this with check or do
we have a better team plan
oh comment about if you're not a
grandmaster by 15 you'll never be good
i disagree but i do agree that if you're
not a grandmaster
by 15 you it's highly unlikely for you
to become a world
champion because i mean in chess it's
not just about
uh the the like the the title it's like
you get
grandmaster at what like 2500 but you
need to be like 2700 plus to be invited
to a lot of these super events super
tournaments
so the later you um get that grandmaster
norman titles you're the the less likely
it will become for you to cross that
2700
barrier and a lot of chances with
maturity too
so a lot of the people that i know who
have become grandmasters
in their teen years they are not
necessarily
crossing 2 700 anytime soon either
so it really depends on the support that
you have from family
friends emotional support financial
support
just it's a whole lot of different
variables
so uh i don't like bishop d7
first of all it just two pieces are
defending it i don't
like it second of all knight effect
relax
you are good yeah knight g5 now the
tables have turned haha remember like
five moves ago maybe like three moves
ago i was talking about how
black is playing in the king side what's
playing between coincide
well black changed that because black
started to make moves in the queen side
it gave
white enough time to start organizing
stuff in the king side
so knight g5 there we go
and in this game
evangel played queen h5 now why to do
white to move
what should we do
the move that cross and played is not
necessarily the only way to win
there white still does have advantage
without doing what carlson did
but i thought it's a very um the the
reason i'm showing you this game is
because of this move so good luck
what do you guys think i think i'll give
you maybe about a minute
[Music]
another subscriber lovely keep it going
keep it coming i don't know which one to
use
whatever it is keep subscribing thank
you
so it's kind of funny because if
vontruck thought that this queen
this position is fine and he's naturally
in trouble
but black is in deep trouble how can we
actually uh open that can of worms
take your time try to find it if you are
watching this video later on
pause pause pause pause and then look it
because
this is a very very very fun thing
coin c4 that's not the move that was
played in the game
nope 24 i think white still does hold a
mini advantage
nothing that big nothing that small but
not the move
so yeah we are right h7 square is weak
so who's defending h7
night and clean can we somehow so these
pieces the knight and the queen are
overloaded
how can we use that how can we use
overloaded pieces
say we're getting somewhere
what do you think how to use overloaded
pieces
we can do this come on guys and gals
g4 just weakens your kick my king is
no i'm gonna keep my king safe and tidy
oh nope so
overloaded doesn't mean that i want to
attack it it means that i want to use
the fact that it's
so preoccupied with this pawn that's
can't really um
do stuff with the other he can't really
perform his other responsibilities so
what other responsibility does this
knight have currently
kind of spelling it out over here
d7 right that's another small
responsibility
that black's knight has and magnus
beautifully went
boom nice yep
exactly now if you decide to take it
back well that's not gonna be pretty i'm
just gonna take it over here
and then bishop g6 queen gotta go let's
say
h6 and i have well your coin falls do
you put it to put it blunt
to put it just to summarize it queen is
gone basically
all right and if you do like queen g4
now f3 and this queen will be trapped
that queen is falling so yeah um
there is a question about what if g6
here so if g6 i could just eat this with
a bishop now
and if you take back now take this and
your king is
just sad sad
sad sad king oh bishop e5 maybe at some
point
yeah i will also want to throw in a
bishop e5 in there this is like plus
four for white white is super winning
and yeah all right i just wanted to
briefly mention this g6 as well
and when queen h5 happened rook d7 in
the game black did not take it he just
went for king h8 to strengthen
survive it and also i want to point out
bishop d7 does
not work which this one actually blows
out all the advantage
because we don't really have a threat
with this we're not really attacking
anything
it gives black enough time to activate
his pieces with knight c5
now let's say you come back you ate a
pawn right but that doesn't matter
because this this game is not about pawn
a lot of the time
chess is about just pawn eating but
that's not one of these times
now it's about all about piece activity
actually i like chess is never about
eating ponds this is all about peace
activity sometimes that peace activity
results in eating all blah blah blah
but you shouldn't be chasing pawns
if it means if it costs you peace
activity oh there you go oh that's
actually a good quote
all right now rick d7 and
king went to jade okay now what should
we do with this rook
should we just move it around or should
we just keep the piece
like should we just develop this other
guy because that's our one last
piece in need of a development so
honestly rook 81 might be the the best
movie in the game but
magnus one for rookie seven this is this
is another this is good
move but you're taking like um
you are choosing material you are
uh he decided to keep your material
rather than
uh like initiative and peace activation
and all those
you know cliches that we always talk
about uh yeah
rook d1 could have been more interesting
which then i could try to ah
thank you for another subscriber then i
could try to continue
like if you take it then i could take
that brook now this is like super
super super rook out there rooks do love
seven drank
that is not a cliche yeah so that's
something that just keep in mind i don't
know if i would do it in the game
that rook defores also suggested that we
could just you know go at it with the
pawn
nothing wrong with that either but i
think rookie 7 might
just be as interesting and this is kind
of fun because we're not
even 20 moves in and black is so um
what's the right word that's won't get
me in trouble
black is so uh tied up
i guess not exactly my word choice but
yeah rookie seven and um
like black's piece activity is just sad
so
uh evanchak would try to dug himself out
of this hole
but it's not really working out that
well
what do you think white should do after
this move the rest of the game is pretty
easy
this move is not that crazy okay maybe a
little crazy but again if you look into
the concept
of um peace activity and the overloaded
pieces again so stretch on this identify
which piece of opponent is overloaded
and for those of you who are playing and
just listening to my voice from a
different tab
make sure to save your games and upload
them to leeches or play on leeches
and have them ready because shortly
we're gonna switch to twitch and
analyze your games
just a heads up subscribers will be
prioritized
but it's open to all
uh now we're not pieces are not ready so
this queen is overloaded queen is
overloaded defending h7 it's not exactly
defending anything else because the
queen is not exactly
under attack right now but it definitely
could
so um moda you have the right square
not the right piece you gotta bring the
bishop to g4
so another good idea is rookie 5 i think
rocky 5 is also
pretty interesting and then we just have
an
f3 and this is a very strategically
a winnable game brooke's sacrifices are
got their fun
or blunders or not gonna be very careful
sacrifice and blunder are not the same
thing
all right so bishop g4 and now if you
take it well that's going to check me
doing one move this even
funner and if queen g6
we don't necessarily want to exchange
queens if you want us to exchange queens
as black you gotta you gotta
put on more work you can't just like hey
game exchange queen and i'll be like
okay
it doesn't work like that you gotta buy
just clean some dinner first
so uh what are we gonna do any checks in
this position
any fun takes anything
anything interesting
exactly nice check yeah if you take it
well that's going to be fun because
now i will exchange this queen and i
will just have
extra material nice so after check
king g8 now what do we do
still wants to exchange queens still not
the time
oh yeah bishop of five thank you yeah
bishop f5
and queen target which is just very fun
because i actually did not see that move
coming
uh yeah so this is a little
weird because if you play queen h5 then
g4 and
this queen will fall that's not it's not
about
if if i can keep this queen or not it's
about finding the best
way to make peace with the fact that
this queen is falling
so i mean if it doesn't fall if it still
helps white improve all of our pieces
and
then i think that's like i think this
position
is much better for white rather than
just a queen falling and
anyway so in the game uh electric went
for this
line and now i'm going to take another
quick
pause and ask you guys what do you think
white should do
and again this does give the best chance
for black to fight so this gives black
the best fighting chance
compared to that other position that you
get to keep your clean but
your all the other pieces are just um
heavily misplaced
yeah bring the check king
what was it well you can take it king
can move too but i don't see why that
would necessary
take it check and we eat over there
all right so why to move
what to do keep in mind that black does
have quite a lot of material
in exchange for the queen so how are we
going to be able to use this
can this minor pieces kind of just make
up
for the queen
mathematically yeah but
what about peace activity
i like this idea going with the h-bomb
maybe not yet we still gotta activate
this guy but yeah
that h pawn coming up so rook d one good
idea
he tries to attract his pieces two boom
h4
the idea is clear if you move your king
now i also have queen d4 ideas and
following with h5 or h5 first and then
actually i think h5 first first
nevermind knight nose take over here
and uh i still well white does have
clear advantage in this case
all you gotta do is get your bishop in
this diagonal which shouldn't be that
hard to achieve
and then this is how white will win
sooner or later all right so
not king h8 so if not khad this knight
is falling
what should black do well the answer is
simple it's still in well we're gonna
act with the pieces
idea this is the piece that's activated
h5 activates your pieces and
queen g5 is wrong can you tell me why
what's wrong with queen g5
there's a very weird song in my head i
don't even know what it's called
so what do you think is wrong exactly
rook five thank you
and then we gotta move this queen and
boom rook f4
and black actually ends up catching a
drop
all right so be very careful with that
even though you have clear advantage
just still
be very careful of what's happening and
if you i mean even if you didn't want to
repeat and you just came back then you
would drop this pawn and we don't want
to drop that ball it's a good pawn
so now my queen is under attack where
should i go with the queen
c4 yeah let's take it
all right let's take that
and knight e5 so this knight freed up
but that doesn't mean that
it's uh while black is holding black
still
is in trouble but now at least
peace is not falling now the knights are
getting a little more close to center so
white still should be cautious of what's
going on and
here actually black might have
inaccuracy he should have done knight e6
to
try and keep the knights in the center
slash king side because king side is
this weakness
but he went for a knight c6 now
carson played a very gorgeous move of
rook d5
now you're turning the rook into this uh
attack and
yeah so it's kind of funny let me ask
you what if herc takes e2
why to move what do you think white
should do
this is just supposed to be funny so
don't don't
get hung up on it too much what if
rookie two
any suggestion
yeah just do stuff on d8 even 28 and
that should be it's
yeah background keys by bike
late review after knight e6 this is
another
pretty beautiful move that magnus played
queen to c4
just it's not like it's not like a super
move
but it is like slowly slowly preparing
for
more that's what i like about it so yeah
um queen c4
and queen e4 would have also been
interesting
because it's like a bunch of pins and
bunch of different ways of attacking
yeah if queen e4 sorry yeah queenie four
would have also been interesting
and queen eight four would have also
been interested too a lot of like little
like little these uh queen ideas
and then you could just bring more
pressure
all right it
could get lower all right so let's say
queen went to c4 and knight
d8 so one uh
one kind of final question black made a
mistake
how can we continue why to move
what's the winning move here again to
clarify there are
a lot of moves that white can do to hold
advantage even like a lot of advantage
like plus four plus three advantage
but this is a winning move what do you
think is this winning move
and 98 was a bad move knight to e7
should have been played
no rook 28 is too early for something
like that
our queen is still misplaced just
because my queen went to
queenside doesn't mean that it can't
come back to kingside
right so
again even this even if black didn't
play knight d8 and he just played like
97
it doesn't mean that black is holding it
just kind of
makes it a little bit longer
yeah queen g4 good job and if you play
king h8 that's not really gonna hold
either
because now just boom bring in the
bishop and
that'll be it yeah
so even if like so now in the game he
just played
knight g7 and that's uh bishop fell
and yeah that was kind of it he
eventually resigned and this
game helped magnus get one step closer
to
breaking kasparov's record all right so
that is all the time i have for chess on
psychology on youtube today i hope you
guys enjoyed it
now i want you i want to meet you in
twitch and our twitch channel in about
10 minutes we're going to take a quick
break make some changes to the channel
grab some tea pay some respects maybe
hug the cat and i'll see you guys in
about 10 minutes
on twitch don't forget to bring a game
that you played on leeches or alicia's
link
and yeah